have you ever had someone explained
grammar to you maybe you had a slip of
the tongue and know-it-all friend of
yours didn't hesitate to point out your
mistake or maybe you were learning a new
language and your teacher told you how
to pronounce a certain letter in
different contexts chances are these
people gave you linguistic rules that
went something like oh this one plural s
sounds likes after voiceless consonants
but likes after voiced consonants rules
like this one are supposed to tell you
how the language works and what's more
they're not supposed to be broken a
paradigm called optimality theorem takes
issue with this approach instead of
applying unbreakable rules to language
optimality theory contends that viola
Balcon P ting constraints do a better
job of explaining how language works
before we take a peek at the guts of
this model let's get a sense of the
difference between a rule-based and a
constraint based approach say you have a
very principled friend who lives life by
a bunch of rules she really sticks to
one of those rules is don't stay up late
another friend of yours doesn't have a
rule like this but does have a bunch of
preferences and demands on their time
things like get enough sleep and play
video games for fun the first friend
expects her rule to be followed never
broken
so it's inviolable the second friend has
a list of constraints she ranks the
constraints by priority sleep above
games a situation arises both friends
are invited to an all-night game fest
the first friend checks her rule the
plan doesn't pass so the outcome is she
doesn't go the second friend compares
her constraints and since she can't
sleep and play games going to sleep
violates the low rank constraint while
playing video games violates the hiring
constraint she chooses the best outcome
the optimal candidate going to sleep
both friends ended up sleeping so our
debate isn't over the outcome it's about
the process optimality theory claims to
be a better model even for what the
first friend is doing in this situation
well at least when we take it back to
language so the same goes when we
consider the input bag plus plural s
with constraints like match voicing and
keep the sounds identical we could end
up choosing between the candidates bags
and bags what's the output going to be
since the pronunciation bags incurs the
least serious violations here it's our
optimal candidate other candidates might
do even worse like if we added bags this
little evaluation table here gets called
a tableau and optimality theory notice
one more time that the constraints are
ranked and viable it's also proposed
that there's a constant tension between
markedness constraints ones that shape
words and sounds and faithfulness
constraints ones that keep words and
sounds the same
I just wanted to leave you with the gist
of the basics of optimality theory I'm
sure you have other competing
constraints on your own time so thanks
for taking a moment to learn